foreign
[Music]
holy [__] [__]
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy [__] [__]
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
oh language the baby's here
yo what up everybody Roy and kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is Gamestop I love this guy
[Applause]
retail Traders I'm hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying
money man happy to take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it
if it's hedge fund [__] make a [__]
ton of money
70 000 people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
GameStop those shares not stopping no
stock is only gonna go up when they hit
I'm gonna buy you a mansion let's drink
to that my brother is a [__] nerd
Wall Street must be seeing this right
holy [__] [__] holy [__] you should
probably dial in holy [__] [__] do
you have a minute I uh
um babe how much did we make today five
million how much did we lose today a
billion and yesterday four million and
yesterday a billion
yeah
[__] rich
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated
surprise surprise you have to testify
before Congress the game has changed
a lot of people feel the system is
broken
the whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
[__] balls
maybe now there is [__] yeah
[Music]
foreign